hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
this is Tamra's never seen today I am
watching spirited away thank you that is
just what the doctor ordered
this is a requested movie that I get all
the time and I think I'm gonna love it
so without further ado here we go Oh
magnificent oh my god you guys that's
all I have to say right you guys know
that this is incredible and beautiful so
alright end of review great haha do you
guys next week bye the movie starts off
and they're driving to a new town and
they're moving and Chihiro has to go to
a new school and I'm like okay well it's
going to be the story of this girl who
go through the school it doesn't have
any friends and you know something we've
seen a million gazillion times just oh
my god it was not even close to that at
all even a little tiny tiny bit I didn't
have my notebook so all of my notes are
written down on my phone I apologize I
don't know what for that's fine but I
wrote is this considered anime I've
never given enemy a chance
I watched Pokemon a bitch with my little
brother we snuck it we weren't allowed
to actually watch it I've never
recovered but my brother when he got a
bit older watched Digimon and yugioh and
Naruto and I hated them I think I was
going through my own school for
everything stage Oh what is this it is
this what anime is that because I hadn't
loved this I also wasn't expecting to
love the characters as much Chihiro
comes out and she starts up and she's
kind of really annoying I was like gosh
staying at the main character but then
you start to just love this little girl
and she heroes like super scared and
she's like I don't want to be here let's
go which at first I was like what
exploring an old abandoned theme park
would be the coolest thing and the dad
leaves them to the okapi restaurant that
has food with his nose ah such the
parents start like pigging out and the
weirdest scene ever two heroes like no
thank you no thank you and so she goes
off on her own she wasn't
this kid and he is like you can't be
here you have to go and then he see all
these spirits arising like ghosts like
gray blob orbs spirits and she gets back
from Paris and once in the actual fresh
hell is this they're pigs they've turned
into Pig and they're pigs and their
giant pig surprise music so she's
running down the stairs to the boiler
room to get a job this is just so far
from what I thought this movie was going
to be this is when the footballs come
out their cute little fluffy is just
carrying around the coal for the boiler
oh my god the sickos eat very small
stars that's what they eat that's what
they consume to live it's so cute
unfortunately I think I probably look
more like the parents when I'm eating
versus the cute little football star you
what are you gonna do then you see the
boiler man who she is supposed to get a
job from and he has a million arm oh no
oh wow characters named Lin comes in and
night he was Megara and I knew it was
her I knew it was her tangent tangent
okay question though so in the beginning
she seized all of the spirits when she's
still in the abandoned theme park and
they're like the ghosts and then now
she's here and they're all like frogs
and weird like ducks and things were
they like trying to like become whole
and then they get to this place and then
they are whole what I don't understand
what are these giant monster speakers
then you meet you Baba and she is mean
and stephy she's got this awesome lair
that she's in like super cool super
detailed the art and this is really neat
I want to live in the place that she was
it like let me live there let me live
there now you Baba then you find out for
some reason she had taken this oath that
she has to give a job to somebody who
asked for it that's convenient to hero
because now she has a job so I broke
down the pronunciation some people call
him Haku sells like hats like it's like
a hat joke
hackie person and then some people call
him Haku sounds like I sounds like the
villain from samurai Jackson oh sorry
because I'm getting teased in Republic
now you're out oh my god then you Baba
turns into a bird and flies around with
the mini bird that looks like her and
it's horrifying and I love it a lot you
Baba gives her this other name sin yes
since there we go it's lots of names
would you all go I'm very busy so Haku
is trying to help
Chihiro get back to her world with her
parents intact because they're still
currently pigs he's like here's a card
here's a real name to hero and don't
forget it and what she almost had it was
like an hour after she had gotten her
new name and she's like hanging out with
Landy's helping her as well and it's
just awesome characters also the boiler
man is helping her now he's like very
kind and I think that but I said about
him he's very sweet and I like his arm
so then she keeps saying this other
spirit who I am referring to as
puppeyface weird spirit and I love a
happy face weird spirit there's this
giant steak spirit that comes and a
happy face weird spirit helps her with
it and then that giant sink spirit ends
up being this really rich spirit who
gets heard this little medicine ball and
everyone likes her after that because
she got rid of the stink there is just
amazing scene where you Baba is like
looking through a chest of Jen I was
like oh that's me I have that same chest
Jen
this was ice but I kept sigh oh God
gone forever Jade horse I definitely
need all those things the happy face
weird spirit starts to eat everything
and starts giving a bunch of people gold
and he tries to give to hero bunch of
goals and she doesn't want it and he
gets really sad and it's had it so sweet
it goes from huh Wow oh he gets so mad
this is it
he eats her sad I guess keeps eating out
of sadness which staying honestly saying
he eats a human I do the same thing
though
when I get sad I eat people as well that
guys in my stomach
so Obama has a child that she doesn't
let out of this room but the broom is
awesome it's got these really cool toys
and like hundreds of pillows which is a
dream to me and also it has this ceiling
so you can turn a switch for and it
shows the Sun and then you turn the
switch and it shows the moon then you go
to sleep this night I'm obviously the
only he wasn't being kept there as a
prisoner he's really cool a spirit that
looks like you Baba comes into the room
and certs up and then you find
out her twin you Baba has a twin who
wears the same outfit that's her I
always thought that was weird
be your own self do your own thing come
here
she turns the baby and weird birthday
into an adorable little rat hamster and
a tiny little bird that carries the rat
hands around and it's adorable so
basically now is when it really starts
getting into like the juice of the story
- Hiro is like well I gotta help out too
because I love Haku that was my cat
darting away and ruining everything
she also heals a happy face weird spirit
and by giving him the little medicine
ball the shoes gonna give to her parents
she gives it to the happy face weird guy
instead and then he shirts throwing
stuff up and then he turns nice again
I'll of him I don't love him I love how
to face weird spirits I wrote he's
lonely
I still like him such a hero save Haku
by returning the gold thing to me Baba
please stop ruining everything Wendy
such a hero just like comes in and saves
the day on so many levels she returns
the thing then she makes friends with
the Baba's sister and now called her
granny if she stays a - she finds out
what his real name is and now he can
escape as well then she's able to let go
back with her parents her and Haku are
like in love though I think they're like
12 which is questionable still very cute
and I'm still very into it not knocking
and I'm just saying it's kind of weird
click a little on I mean can't fault me
for that guys
the 12 I think we're dunker maybe I
don't know but I'm rather they go back
through the tunnel and the car has a
bunch of like debris on it and it's all
dusty like the time had passed I loved
that it was like nothing ever happened
you nothing you never move remember this
and it's like no she will and kind of
definitely pass I like that a lot and I
also wasn't the dad brings it back to
the whole like first turmoil which is
like a new town and a new school is
pretty scary
heroes like I'm pretty sure I can handle
it dad so yeah that's somebody the
artwork was incredible the voice acted
was super fun I don't know I just how
anime is because I love this not
surprising because literally everyone
loves this and I knew that I was going
to it just surprised me so much in a way
that was like the story did not go where
I thought it was beautiful I really
think that Haku dragon form is just like
a more badass balfour I'm not dissing
south or south or it's pretty badass she
was like my favorite part of that movie
but damn Haku coming in with the swipe
taking it over so a lot of these things
that I'm watching your things that I'm
like oh of course it is he is because I
wouldn't have been allowed would have
not been okay in my household who is
social thanks for watching see you guys
next week
I adore you goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]